you
[Music]
good morning everyone I'm happy to have
dr. Chang deal as our speaker today and
our son Connelly is a portable
researcher at a UC Berkeley and he got a
PhD from University of Milan and it has
a reason increased frozen intersection
particularly insecurity in the program
language a win several peri-peri work
yeah thank you very much for for the
nice introduction so today I'm very
happy to be invited here to share my
experience on how to use deep learning
to help enhance the security and
probably the language and okay so let's
just started it
okay so consider we are just our average
PhD student okay so I shouldn't use the
term average but so I'm what I mean is
that assume that so we are not having
any security security background then
and we are asked to develop some some a
system for example like the autumn
autonomous driving system are the crypto
currency contracts or even the
recommendation system so then what what
what can you how can you do to guarantee
the security of this system so first of
all why do we want to guarantee the
system security of this system
because otherwise if you don't make sure
they are secure then you have you will
be on the Han line of some use right for
example the your information will be
beaked to publicly and accidentally I
also may be in the most terrible case
then you're the car that you are driving
will crash into some other cars and also
you you may happen to lose a lot of
money right so you know all these
different applications it highlights the
importance of making sure that the
systems that you are building is secure
and actually this is a challenging
problem so my research focus is how can
we use different technologies and also
the problem analysis technology to
guarantee the security of when we build
this kind of season so my main research
on these programs and then in today's
talk I will talk about two aspects first
of all I will consider so if we
represent these programs as a into a
neural network then what will be the
problem and then I will review that
these are resistance of the desired
water examples will hinder the
application of the RF of such systems I
will very soon introduced what I mean
and later I for the second part of the
talk I will introduce our work using
deep learning to improve the security of
different kinds of programs ok so ok
let's just get started so in recent
years there are more and more interest
to kind of represent the entire program
as our internal neural network for
example this is a simple this is a a
multi-layer multi-layer perceptual
network that can classify the input
image which is just a unit into input is
cloth so this part is called image
classification it has to achieve huge
amount of access in recent years and
actually the Samsung latest architecture
has been able to surpass humans
capability in this task however the use
istant of so-called edgewater example
will hinder such applications for
example this is a this is a resonant
model so on the left hand side on these
three columns on the left hand side
there are just regular and they are just
original images in the data set so and
then for a well trained model they can
classify Auden correctly oh sorry I
don't know what's wrong with this but it
happens sometimes I don't know what's
wrong with that but right so but we can
add some perturbation that is in the
middle and then we got a result image
which look identical to the first column
to human beings but for the neural
networks all these images will be
classified as ostrich
so this examples are so-called adversary
examples and we we all know that they
are not correct and more importantly
this will severely hindered application
of some security sensitive our
application one of them is this autumn
autonomous driving system for example
the this kind of system will rely
heavily on on different sensors to
science for example the traffic sign
around around along the road and for
these two signs I think so so here so
anyone can tell the difference between
the two right okay so you want to have a
shine right this I'm very sorry about
this problem but I don't know I don't
know why it just lies automatically but
but actually so so on the paper that
presented in you know paper that the top
image is shown as a stop sign button
bottom images reported as a yield sign
so and then so the so the difference
between stop sign and yield sign may be
may be fine but for some for sometimes
if you predict the stop sign as a for
example de for example as the speed
limit sign then that would be a big
problem because you won't stop there
right so so you know all these different
respects it is very important to study
these adversary examples okay so we
consider the uses in work and now we
found that most of them are only
considering this image classification
problem and then also they all consider
the target model is not that means not
only the parameters in the model unknown
but also hot how the network use those
parameters compute the final result is
not so in our investigation we want to
see two aspects the first one is whether
we can weaken the very muddled for
example we whether we can generate this
adversary examples when the target model
is
none also we want to see where they are
the class other classes of models are
also vulnerable to these adverse are
examples so here is a real system that
is called clarified comm this is a this
is a star's startup in the area and then
the main the main service that it
provides is that you can upload user
capture the image are into the system
and then the system will return a couple
of labels that they believe this image
contains and then use for this system so
we are not collaborating with their
company but we just use this system to
see whether we can attack that so for
the so this isn't the model that they
used to to predicted to make the
prediction is unknown also they're
finding data isn't not and more
importantly even though even these this
label sets is and not because we don't
know what label could be returned from
from the system so and then we want to
see whether we can tag tags okay
so right now I want to briefly explain
how these adversary examples are
generated so the basics and techniques
to generate this adversary example is
through this this maximization problem
and then so we assume the model is FC
tags where theta is the parameter in the
model and how is the loss function just
as the same one as we use in done as we
used during the fini
so during the training we want to
minimize the loss where the parent are
and where the parameter to optimize is
the is Theta but here for for adversary
example we want to maximize the loss
that means we want the prediction to be
far away from the ground truth so and
then the and then also we don't change
anything about the parameter but we only
change the input so that we want to find
the input x star which is which can make
the make the prediction far away from
the ground rules and also we don't want
to generate an arbitrary arbitrary input
we hope the input
the so-called adversary examples are
still very close to the Orangina input
so that is why we have another country
here we hope so d here is a as a decent
and function which is a metric and then
we hope the distance between two
instances are very close for example
bounded by a constant B right so by
solving these are so all different kinds
of adversarial are all different kinds
of algorithm to generate adversary
examples are solving this problem are
approximating the solution of this
problem so I will enumerate two classes
why it's called the iterative approach
there for example we can use a gradient
descent based algorithm for example in
most of our approach we use the Adam
optimizer and then we have optimized the
following the following objective which
is the deal form of the the previous our
optimization problem and then here we
just added put together with a hyper
parameter lambda in here so we can
decide the lambda empirically to based
on the result of our generator other
example and then typically we can run
the atom optimizer within within 100
iterations under the generating
adversary example are very very good
which means that they can totally food
for the model and also the perturbation
is very small also recently researchers
are more interested in this so-called
fast approaches the benefit is that they
are so this approach is don't need to do
either it either
iterative algorithm so they only need to
compute the greedy ones so that is much
faster than the iterative iterative
approach so the basic idea is that so so
we just want to compute the distance
between X and X star directly based on
the gradient right so so we just can
compute this gradient and then for the
first quiz design we take the sine of
that and for the first reading that is
what we developed that is we not
this gradient and the other other be in
front and them and put our internal
business yes right so right but right
this is so so far I'm talking about how
to attack the model in the whiteboard
model so I haven't touched to the to the
part of blackboard yet so I will soon go
there
great that's a good question okay so
these are right so as I just explained
that these are all the different
approaches to generate a laboratory
example you know by both model and then
the problem is that we have to need to
know this model itself so the real
question is how can we attack the model
we don't know in this paper parameters
and we even we don't we don't even know
the function f here right so there's an
intriguing property called
transferability so that was also
identified by the 2014 paper it says
that the anniversary samples generated
for one model can transfer to the other
so what does it mean is that for example
we consider this truth and then the one
truth is a running shoe right so this
image is generated for the model vgcc
which was our state-of-the-art model for
image net and therefore based on for
that model we can misclassified this
image into the military uniform and then
interestingly we only when we generate
this image we only touch the model of
vgg succeeds but when we evaluate over
several other models like the state of
art resin model google net model they
are all classified in into the wrong
class even though the charts are
different right so so this demonstrates
the transferability
really use this even in this state of
large models so then based on this
property we can generate we can build
that the following attack scheme so the
idea is that we have the bypass system
then the adversary can generate a white
box mode
themselves you see using different kind
of technique under the Iowa so you can
generate adverse or example against
those wipeouts models and then with the
high probability decide was our example
will transfer to that palapas model yes
it's the system that is so if you can
use this everything examples to retain
the underlying middle area and robust
tool is kind of like a this is one of
the most most hot topic discussed in the
in this area and we are so we are
writing some papers to show that this is
not indeed the case right so right so so
there is a long debate whether adversity
is helpful or not against again to
defend against those side of us are
examples but actually we found we found
that they are just another form of
overfitting that count
so the routine model just overthrew
those generated that was our example but
you always have other ways to generate
adversary's on but I can steal food the
retained model right right that's a good
question yet
so there are there are different
approaches well process that you can
generate these web loss model using the
so culture surrogate model that is that
you have a you have a cross of input and
then you submit them to the plateaus
model and then you can get it as we you
can get an answer from that and then you
can retrieve model yourself using the
web boss model then then using this way
that's called the surrogate model
approach but in our experiment we just
saw we just try about model ourselves
for example using the image metadata we
are not touching this hypothesis and
first number the clarify come at all and
then we would I will show very soon that
they can still transfer right so okay so
this is the basic scheme but here before
I go into the detail I want to I want to
make a distinguish distinguish between
the two cross are offer tax why is
called the non are
and the other called targeted for
example for the image not data set there
will be 10 1000 different classes for
every image it has a long fuse so we say
that it's a non targeted that was very
example if the model will classify the
image into any wrong class right so you
have 999 different choices for useful
for the model but for the target here
that was our example we manually pick a
concept class that is far away from the
far away from the consul's you will soon
see how we pick the model how we pick
the target label and then and then so
you hear over the 1000 different classes
you only have one choice to for the
model took into ok we found that for the
non targeted inaudible for example they
transfer very well so I just don't show
their their performance but for the
target II that was our example the
transferability is very poor so how to
read easy how to read this table so we
we basically gathered 6 different kind
of models from from ResNet to the
inception when we did this the latest
inception is still inception v3 but we
are not there there before
so we generated the Vasser example for
different roles
oh so first of all we collect 100
different images that can all be
classified correctly by all these
different models and then we generally
adversary example for different roles
and then we evaluate them over the
different columns and then for each cell
that is based on this that is the
accurate that is the matching read of
hardwood with how this generation as was
your example perform so what is the
machinery that means for example for
this cell that means we generated the
targeted ad vitur example for BG 16 and
then we evaluate on resin activity and
we want to see how many of them will be
classified into the target class but we
live that we manually choose right and
we found the accuracy is the measure
residual only 2% diamond is only 2 out
of 100
images are classified by resonate 50
into our design target class but this is
not because our general and our advisor
examples are generated poorly because
for the main document we can see that
the accuracies are all 100% that means
they can all for the model that you are
using to generate the model it's just
the transferability is pull so okay then
here is the scene so for example we have
this water buffalo image and then for
clarified comment they can or they also
can classify that very well and then how
can we make clarify calm believe that is
a rugby ball right so here we can see
the concepts are very different from
each other okay as we mentioned that the
the transferability for generative for
one model is very cool so our idea is
very simple so we can use sample do all
different kinds of models and then we
can generate diverse or example based on
the example model turning this in this
way we hope the the transferability of
these charities not example are better
and then our experiment indeed show the
case for example for this okay I admit
there are a lot of noises on here but
you can usually still be able to see
this is a this is a buffalo some some
kind like that party in the river
passing the label return from clarify
calm we can observe that past time boss
part and games which are very relevant
to the put a target label that we gave
which is a rugby ball right so then we
say this is a successful target attack
and then I also like to show you
something more like for example this is
a broom image and then we want the prior
photo company that is a bird and then PI
D some noise it is indeed believe so so
it indeed please the most likely label
for this image is a bird unfortunately
no right now so that so we have the
image in our ripple but not in the slide
the image can you listen to that song
bird or some no no so they just look
like they just look alike random noise
yeah yes in fact clarify are you using
why these game yards yes
it seems like clarify review when you
say the art object recognition inside
reality I mean not fur but right about
the past clearly and right one creatine
is that their labels that is totally
different than what we are using like
the huge net labels so the images are
not labels like the jicama doesn't
appear anything in here image labels
from unit subset with their showings we
have extra labels that that might be
possible but so how is it does the key
the key pond is that we don't have
knowledge any knowledge about this right
like a safari probably right but that's
all right so actually with how to
clarify people during during right here
so where this paper is published so
under they also didn't mention that they
are not using they are also not
mentioning so what what model they are
using on whether whether this is because
maybe the model is come is indeed
resonate or it is because something like
that so very clearly clearly they don't
write clearly they don't tell us right
but but these are just some results as
read that we can show and also the last
the last one is fruit is kind of recruit
and we want to make the decision to
believe that the stupa and and actually
when we generate this I believe that is
a temple which is a channeling Master
supa
right so okay so for this work with
honestly that it's not necessary oh I
also want to mention that for this so
for this we increase the scale of the
perturbation so that the noise level is
very large but actually when we decrease
that to about 1/2 so we we
don't have demonstration here but when
we decrease that it can still feel
clarified butter ism but just with fewer
examples fewer successful examples right
so at this level of noise we can so out
of 100 out of 100 examples there will be
more than 20 examples back and further
for the system successfully right so
right this is just something that I'd
like to mention and the main takeaway
here is that too for this kind of system
you don't even need to know the model
employers are deployed in into your
system but to you but you can still
perform successful attacks against these
kind of models so this will this
highlights the importance of why we need
to study these are what we need to study
that was our example because because
this will make and this will make the
attack seem very simple to deploy in the
real case okay so besides besides Lee
yes so in the interval training example
before with you to the traffic signs in
support here it's not an image that you
have to change in some way to in an
adversarial way it see it's a real world
that UB needs change
yes human yes see records also that's a
very good question so we're not to know
the model
so can you do that we will see soon
right because we are we are also
experiment induce so but there is a
there's a paper released from CMU so
they show that you can take designs on
paper crosses so their target is a face
recognition system and then you were the
paper crosses and then you go into you
go into the camera which will identify
whether you are some celebrity and then
they cancel they can make you make the
system BB view that you are some
celebrity like process of an awesome
someone like like that is a very high
confident
so this demonstrate that it is indeed
possible to to to do this real real
world attack but so far for the traffic
song we haven't
tiny mouth environments yet but I hope
more is also will appear coming soon yes
what am i a practical Christian are you
attacking you you catch unique and
understand then you write so we hope
that for example like I'm like I
demonstrated before that in the in the
autonomous driving system so they just
use a camera to catch those different
traffic signs and then this is the
simplest simplest application target
attack scenario that you can apply this
technique for example you want to you
want to kill some car for example Tata
just for example and then maybe you can
get your security phone calls you catch
image and you just oh no no they are so
select the like the question that I just
answered before the images captured by
the camera on your device rights also
with only two per person we don't need
to inject adverts or camera for you so
so we just for example we can just plot
something on the 13th I often see
something that is almost invisible to
human beings but you can but for the
camera which which can capture that
image is finding it already
automatically for your system you really
find a very simple donation and you are
so so let me tell you why an experiment
done by Google so this is done by Google
so they generally return it was very
example but this is not by nature but
they generated underwater example and
then print that on a paper and then they
use the camera to to to to take a photo
of the paper and then they will
recognize what what this photo is about
and then in this way they can further
they can further image classifier within
the phone entirely so in this in this
tracking all the other devices that you
are using for example the tool the
camera in the
is the phone the camera in the phone are
all your device so we are not ready
Eckert doesn't doesn't plug in any kind
of adverse or pull you into those
devices but only the image itself is is
injective on my level so perturbation
right so I hope this kind understand
answer your question okay I think right
so we need to move a little faster for
the following part so we also
demonstrate that the generative models
are also vulnerable to these kind of a
device or examples so so can I ask how
many people here are familiar with
charity model okay pretty a lot so that
I can save a lot of time so basically
generate a generative model is a contain
user encoder and a decoder so the
encoder part will convert the input or
Anjana input into a much shorter vector
representation and the decoder will
become the code that simply code a
shorter representation which we call
embedding into the orange node vector so
we hope that so the point of generative
model is that the decoded image will
look very similar to the orange in the
image but with a mostly that we can
inject noise onto the orange and image
so that the decoded image can be fully
totally fooled so here is an example
this is the you know I missed so this is
the orange Inori meeting so we can
retrain a very good we vary variation
auto encoder and then the generated at
the recover the image look very similar
to the original image right and then in
this case we set the target image say
zero and then we can construct the
so-called advisory examples that's just
look like printing the these pivots on
on a bad quality paper so there are a
lot of background noises here but the
point is that very amazingly after the
reconstruction everything it becomes 0
right so this demonstrate that this
generative model is also very easy to
fool and it's not only four digits but
also for okay this is also digits but
the
on the real street street view they can
all be reconstructed into zero or even
faces can be reconstructed into a
woman's face okay
so bye-bye here we demonstrate that this
kind of this kind of mean you like
generative model are still vulnerable to
either motor examples okay then you may
be asking questions about gun but we
don't have in Furman here but the hours
of practice that guy is also likely to
be vulnerable
okay the next why is that so we also
test whether this kind of deep policy
for example the reinforcement learning
system also vulnerable to these
anniversary examples so we study this
h3t which is a which is a combination of
actor and critique parts into into the
reinforcement learning system so i want
to check how many of you are familiar
with these h3c organ already okay so
maybe a half of you so I will do a brief
introduction traduction so for the photo
for the active so ACC is a combination
of actor and critics for the actor part
it is specifically a policy network for
example when you are playing this pong
game then based on the based on the into
the image the policy network director
part will decide whether you go up or go
down so the decision is totally based on
the based on the current state itself
then for the critique part it will it
will generate I will compute a value
function to evaluate to evaluate if you
take some merchants and however how much
reward you will get in the future in the
in the long run right
so one y is used so the extra part is
only based on the current for amended
the creepy part will consider the reward
in the future so if you understand right
if you don't understand it you can just
take it okay so we demonstrate that we
can train our with answering a sec
network that can play very well which is
the left hand side we can see that they
can easily win window on a window
baseline approach but actually we can
inject adversary's ampuls into into into
these are into every frame and then to
folder policy network and then basically
we have observe that the basically the
agent the same agent used by the left
hand side on the right hand side but on
the right hand side cannot catch even a
single ball and the more efficiently you
can I believe you cannot observe the
difference between the left hand side
under rampa but I can tell you that on
the right hand side there are already
are also preservation injected right so
this is this democracy at acting the
policy network it is very effective to
attack the system but more interestingly
you don't even need to attach the actor
part you can click you can attack the
critic part which is the value function
then when you attack the value of an
changes are when when increasing
observation we found is that you don't
even need to inject the every single
frame
you only need to inject that was our
perturbation every time frames so this
will reduce dudes will reduce a lot of
that was our example that you need to
inject it and which also means that you
can weaken the threat model that you
have yes no no no no no there are all
trends based on you know model right so
we have experiment that I was a refinish
is indeed helpful in this case but I
just don't have the results show showing
up in my slice yes yes during training
rather than in France yeah yeah apart
yet why we attacking a very function
during interest have an effect on a
popular that it's very very oh that's a
good question a fortune I cannot answer
this question right now but I can
double-check gray
yes technically i Function partner what
you mean by attacking these value
functions also so as I mentioned that
there is a actor part and there's a
critique part so basically the last
experiment only attack the actor part so
this this is firmly attached to the
critic part of the model okay so right
so okay so by the most recent piece so
we are not so this is this pong game is
just a simple simple example that we
want to demonstrate but more important
more importantly we want to demonstrate
that this kind of reinforcement learning
system which are heavily used in for
example robotics and so our sub training
systems are also very vulnerable to
these adversary examples also to attack
these systems we don't even need to
inject adversary examples into every
frame but we can inject them sparsely
into for example I returned frame
argument every time difference okay so
okay so that is the first part about our
study our adversary examples and then
and then in the following I will discuss
so so this shows that using this entire
neural network is vulnerable very likely
to be vulnerable to this okada those are
examples there are alternative is that
we convert and we return back to this
discrete programs or hybrid programs
which combine in the neuro part and the
discrete part then my the second part of
my talk it will be introduced in some of
our work about how to use a deep
learning to improve the security of
these kind of programs yes what is the
only message that you have now there is
a situation objects because you said
that you came in
that's a good question
yes so we saw the first message that we
we want to send is that these are the
voter examples
need more attention from the research
community because they are so prevalent
in all different kind of systems so so
here are just some demo examples that we
demonstrate that was or examples are
exist but for for a lot of other ISM for
a lot of other systems they also use
these so and also it also highlights the
importance of we need to build it
depends and and by showing that we can
employ a very weak certain model we
demonstrate that by building our defense
is a very challenging problem because we
almost demonstrate that you don't even
need to know the model you that is the
white box of the model then you can
attack the system you know proper
setting so so then then it also shine
your lights into how house we consider
the defense algorithms in the field in
future research for example when we
build the defense whether we tank
whether we test that in the white box
model or whether we should take that in
the blood loss model right so yeah so I
think these are the main takeaways of
these works yes assumption vintage-y
hotspot will knowledge UNIX generated as
there is also consumer to that one
solves generated P so you could imagine
you could mention the clarifies invented
richness and not told anyone about it
right and the rest of us refusing DG or
elephant or whatever and you could do an
ensemble over though there's a generator
thoroughly gone for sure but but thing I
mean would you still be able to generate
atmospheric on facility that's a very
good question but the most important
organ question is in this field
so actually we want to what you did want
to study the the similarity between
different models at least from the frogs
we just look at the model superficially
their model architecture
are totally different so they share the
parameter stream even for the same model
that we treated with the two different
set of random initialization the model
the parameters in the model are also
totally different right so so
superficially they are not the same but
there are some common similarity in
between of them for example they must
have all have a very good test accuracy
that means when one can be not normal or
in general image so the the prediction
accuracy should be similar right this is
this is really if we look at them at the
wahala what this is the only similarity
that we can talk about right now so and
then there are a lot of theoretical
region study so we have some serious it
will result in our group but we are
writing and actually stamper also have
some theoretical result on some simpler
network that we demo where we want to
show that if the models accurate test
accuracy are similar then whether that
was the design boundary should have some
similarity in between right which is the
main which is a main purpose the main
purpose of our other example is that you
can generate adverse or in perturbation
so that you can go across the decision
boundary right so so the decision
boundary that is the most interesting
thing we are selling but so far we don't
have a very clear understanding of that
yet okay yes so we I mean what if we
apply our executor of the noisy
microphone before the main TN
yeah yeah that is also considered by
this in work and then right people your
they show that there are thousands of
people's right so this is a high-level
message that is so far almost all
existing technique can be attacked right
this is this is a one was a terrible
message but but we are not giving up
this is another important message here
we are still trying to find whether we
computer I was a resident citizen
okay so so I move to the next part
yes thank you so for the second part so
basically I will showcase some of our
studies to show that we can employ
people your network to achieve matter
much better performance on binary
analysis which I will talk about right
after this slide we also demonstrate
some of our programs is it work on
different kind of input types okay so
let's just carve with the author with
the program analysis so so one of the
hottest thing into this word is
so-called Internet of Things or IOT
devices right so there is a prediction
that in you know by 2020 there will be
over 15 million feeding IOT devices in
the world right for all these different
devices then there is an important issue
is there firmwares
so you can consider the framers of the
IOT devices is some kind of operating
system built into a beautiful drive the
device to work and then so there are
some properties of these devices why is
that these these frameworks are written
there their instructions their
instruction set architecture is in
different is different for example some
of them are isolated structures and many
of many of them are arms are meats
because they have lower power
consumption right so on also to write to
implement these framers there there the
binary code are also in different
formats right so so exact here what's
binary code means that basically means
that I think usable code back and
directly around to the CPU because it
always get confused when we will only
jump into this part from the images
right so I hope this is clear and then
there's a comment there's a very severe
problem is that when we build these
firmware images so the current practice
is to employ some common open open
source the
code for example one of the one of the
most heavily employed code is the
OpenSSL because every single IOT device
requires a secure connection component
and then open SSL justice disco and then
so this means that once one
vulnerability identified in in this in
this source code that will affect the
millions or even billions of these IOT
devices the most important or the most
uh resignification the example is this
called a heartbleed that is so I think
many of you should be familiar with that
and then a lot of systems in the
universe have been affected by this ah
this vulnerability so so when these new
vulnerabilities are identified so our
problem definition is that we hope to
design mechanism so that when these
vulnerabilities are newly detected then
we can have a very fast mechanism to see
which are which from our images in
binary code are affected and how can we
fix them right so so let's give it a
more more precise definition so we are
considering we are given two problems
why are the vulnerabilities that may be
compiled from the source code for
example the prefetch the source code and
then the other is just a binary code we
don't know which architecture it is part
of the code itself can tell which
architecture it is and our problem is
one to detect whether two programs are
similar so this problem is very
challenging given these these context of
Ltd devices because the architecture are
so different so that even the code to
compile the code that may have very very
deep and very various various of forms
for example there can their control flow
graph may even not be the same okay
and so the essays are different also the
compiler used to build this binary code
are different also the combination
options for example whether you are
using a one optimization or all three
optimization they are also different so
there are so many various so that's it
if you just consider using our hash
based approach for example you can you
can compute a sha-1 signature of a
binary code on what you want to match
whether the insurance industry matches
the matches matches the vulnerability so
this such kind of work doesn't work just
as an idea just doesn't work right so
then how how can we solve this problem
so in the research community so
basically we consider this foreign form
of architecture to solve the problem so
we have a firmware file so we have the
vulnerability the only can use it is an
assembler to extract the photograph from
the orange you know from from the orange
node binary code so are these in these
Cobras we have some structure that is a
basic basic real graph with some
actually built on each node and then we
computer embedding of these Co graphs so
that they can they will be converted
into into the vector space and then to
test whether to code are similar or not
with simpler use of cosine similarity
between the two embeddings right this is
the high-level idea and then so as you
can see the most challenging part is how
to define this embodying inviting
algorithm right the easy teamwork
employing this idea use pipe and
bipartite graph matching algorithm for
computing body
for example the latent estate Authority
result that demonstrate better
performance than all previous approach
is was just published in CCS 2016 which
is which is our baseline in our come our
comparison in the following right so and
we found this bipartite graph matching
based algorithm is very first of all
it's very slow because bipartite graph
matching is
start slow and also the effectiveness is
not that good because this is a
deterministic cross doesn't considering
any anything else okay so the our
approach take takes another idea that we
can use the people in your network to
learn this embedding automatically right
undoing in this way then we have avoid
the expensive bipartite graph matching
and so that the to compute the invariant
vector it can be very inefficient also
also we can trim the network effectively
so that if the embedding is contains
much more semantic information then
these are manually designed an ad hoc
approach okay so I won't go into the
detail of how we build a network
basically we borrow or one from from
from from this paper that is called
structure to back so basically for a co
graph these structures will back and
convert the input in into the embedding
and then the real problem is how do we
train this network because the orange
and no paper requires a label for each
input so that they can be trained but in
our setting we don't have a label right
so so to mitigate this problem we just
use a CMI's network for example the
CMU's network just contain two identical
networking be inside it and then compute
the cosine and then just you only need
to give two breaths and the label
whether they are similar or not right so
and then this is in this way we can use
to combine the structure to work and the
gemenese networks to train the network
and then I just give you a few
statistics about our how our system
works so first of all the most important
message that we are carrying about is
the serving time so even previously in
previous work is the ccs 16 paper that
was just a several month ago and then it
was for every single input file it will
take a few seconds to a few minutes to
generate the embedding for for just one
input
gray and the using active neural network
it just takes a few milliseconds so
easily compute the improvement that
passed from at least two thousand two
thousand five hundred times speed up and
the most and the patent to the best case
we can achieve over sixty thousand times
Eva so this is a huge improvement in
terms of the serving time also the
training time is also much much reduced
for example in their original in their
orange in the workday requires a
clustering algorithm in the training
which we need to compute a pairwise
component of a very giant matrix so the
the finding time takes more than one
week and on the hour in our case with
two three one good model we only need
less than certain certain minutes so
that is very fast to treat also for the
effectiveness so this is this is just a
table that we demonstrate the current
the correct the vulnerability the w.zahn
so for example we we have a large set of
or 400 meeting samples of paranoid code
and then we catch the most so forth so
this is just one more abilities but we
have several vulnerability in our
experiment so we get the most likely the
most similar ones in the data sets and
we manually look into them whether the
vulnerability exists or not in these
data sets so we found that among the top
50 results we can confirm that 24 for
the two of them are correct are indeed
vulnerabilities and in previous works
the number is only time so this means
that we are average so this is the best
the the best example the best
vulnerability that we can have for our
average within the top 50 results we can
we have identified 25 more vulnerable
falls in the top 50 results
but does data already 30 percent of I
perceive improvements
so any questions so far
yes you mention you donate creating
tables but if it how you're creating the
series necklace right that's a very good
question so we have we have the source
code right for example we can take those
ssl source code and then we can compile
that into different architectures and
different using different compilers and
using different optimization levels and
then we can get a set of different
different different binary codes and
then for the same function in different
is a if they correspond to the same
source code then we label them as
identical otherwise we label them as
different right in this way we can
somehow get a console so that this
network is printable right okay so any
other questions yes so how you answer
what is the input structure the craft
and your article paint application
oh the input is just a graph and honest
no there will be a vector there will be
a small shot vector that is manually
extracted using some serious heuristic
approach and then for so basically the
network is kind of similar to approach
with ease propagation but we will
propagate the vector on each node onto
the onto the adjacent node because each
is we imagine yet the represented
summers are connecting the community
yeah yeah yeah yeah I will take that
into consideration right so all the
other edges in their profit are actually
so so the information just propagates
through that direction from the source
node to the target node this kind of
thing so I don't I don't go into detail
that because that is maybe not not as
the most important part so so the main
takeaway message of this work is that we
just want to demonstrate our using the
internet work it's a help solving this
problem analysis problems and then it
can be more effective and more efficient
so also the problem analysis can be a
normal application domain of these are
often our deep learning technologies
okay yes do you think it's possible to
alternative you so I could imagine that
you will discover a higher level
structure which could correspond to a
whole class availability so do you think
that's a cool question so this is just a
start starting work - Thomas is that
deep learning can be used but if I can
be our next steps as you know our
consideration right so far so far we
always did miss work and then we are
still continuing to some other proneural
analysis tasks right now source code
compiled sure why you just keep changing
both the boundaries for different
options different platform and just have
a hash function yes that's what I
mention at the beginning so because
there are too many often so you cannot
use those really very right the question
is you look at them I don't know so it
is questionable because our
consideration we only found about around
12 different kind of different kind of a
saw on signatures
giving our soul
but can be constructed using our
compiler for example just GCC with
different congressional train but in but
in the dataset we found over 20
different kind of Shaolin signatures so
we don't know and eight they also
doesn't match the signature that we have
but we generated automatically so this
is why I mention at the beginning of the
talk this kind of hostage in face the
approach is not will not work well
because because because there are so
many variants you cannot do I use
audience research yeah that's a good
question
okay I think I need to move to the next
because I still have a lot of things to
talk about about we only we don't have a
lot of time so and right so so uniformly
I will talk about our work on program
synthesis and that this is that this is
a simple work that was our in general
that's what's our engine republish from
Microsoft is here so the talk is that
given a natural language description we
want to produce a so-called Eastern
program so our Eastern program is
basically contain only two parts that's
very simple
so our each which is called figure and
action right only two parts so this is
the simplest sort of program that you
can have right so and then so what what
you can do so we observe that there is a
strong correlation between the terms in
the in the sentence into the prediction
that you need to make so this means for
example when we have these post photos
in your Dropbox folder into to a
histogram then the key word double toe
box will hint that the trigger is very
likely related to topics functions and
the you see Graham there is where is
since that action is very related to
Instagram so the basic idea is that you
can use attention to put different ways
onto different tokens so that you know
where is the most important part in the
sentence when you make the prediction
however using attention itself may make
the mistakes for example you you may
consider
jobox is related to the action and the
you sleep Grammy related to the sugar
then the whole prediction is wrong right
so we found a lot of example of this
scenario in the in the validation set so
this approach is not good so this is why
we introduced this called latent
attention mechanism that can help to
make this prediction that is so in the
sentence we found there are some like
either proposition or some other words
that helps you to locate where is the
trigger and where is the action for
example this word to indicate that the
previous the first part of the sentence
is more related to the trigger and the
fallen and the second part of the
sentence is more related to the action
so in this way we can build a so-called
listener attention architecture which
will put attention first on where is the
key word and then and then based on this
based on this key word we decide how to
put attention on when we predict trigger
actions and then we observe that our our
approach can achieve the state of art
performance on these on this different
kind of task where we are in the left
hand side we only predict the channel
and on our right hand side we only
predict the channel and function so I
may not have enough time on to talk more
about this so if you have questions I am
very happy to talk about that after
after after this so the main takeaway of
this work is that the natural language
is a very convenient way to represent
the functionality of the code to be
synthesized but it is very hard to
guarantee that they are all correct for
example as we can see that hi cereal is
only 90 percent so it is not 100 percent
and also we are not synthesizing an
argument to each function right so and
this is the latest part that most of you
may be interested
that's is we want to try to see whether
we can do info of power program disease
or you can also call that a TV program
by example
so here the the problem that we want to
synthesize is a passer for example we
have an intuitive example we have an
input which is a token sequence and we
have the output tree or we have nothing
else so we want to infer so we also we
of course don't have the grandma the
present production rule of that but we
know that they all belong to the
context-free grammar so we want to learn
these passerbys only on this
input-output examples without any other
supervision so this problem is pretty
challenging when the grammar is unknown
because of the following issue so first
of all for these tokens the input tokens
under the non terminals in the tree
there should be a correspondence that
needs to be learned and second you need
to know the order of order of the input
tokens may not your actually correspond
to the to the pre-visit order of the
production tree for example in this DC
so this is a problem reasoning in
CoffeeScript and then in the produce in
the parse tree but the later part of the
program comes first in the universe tree
ok and also we need to learn this
Association for example in this in this
part if you want to build one if acts as
a subtree this is not valid because
because the Association just doesn't
work like that
so all these challenge challenges make
this problem very interesting to be
considered and so here I briefly review
a lot some really working in this field
the first one that will come into our
mind is the signal to systems like
architecture so and we will demo so this
is indeed our baseline approach to
compare with and we will demonstrate
that this kind of approach is hardly
generalized for longer inputs also there
are a lot of work coming from Microsoft
here for example the r3 and by daniel
rossen
robust feel they consider
to construct on huge network that will
take the examples as the incident and
predicted the program as the outfit
right so this is the basic idea but so
we so but one problem is that the
synthesize the program's length is very
limited so I wouldn't say that it's a
limitation but I think our work is
considering a more complex class of
programs but having the different design
goal between these are these are lines
of work on des and our our research
problem and there is a another important
class of approaches that is called MPI
on uniform an interpreter that basically
learns a new representation of the
program what do I mean is that there is
an underlying environment for example
you can consider the stack or the
machine or the RAM there are all belong
to the environment we can provide
observations and then there is our SPM
but we will take this observation as the
input and then predict what is the next
the next function to the activity or the
next primitive to the activity right and
then so this frontier has demonstrate
the huge success on simple algorithms
like topological sorting our quicksort
but there between these between these NP
is you need full supervision on the
execution trees so you need to know
every single step which are an
instruction to be allocated so and also
the problem implemented to be handled by
NP is red that is a moderately complex
complex but not too complex for example
the quicksort example studied in
previous with paper which is the most
complex example can you know a can be
implemented in Python in three lines of
code but in our in our example the our
parser needs at least pens are one of
the example require more than 100 lines
of code to implement the for passes
I'm not even counting the other
auxiliary countries to our total nice
the implementation simpler okay
so here we have so here we describe the
design goal so first of all our
supervision contains only input and
alpha pairs and second alpha we what we
hope to achieve for generalization that
means once the model is trained on us
small they thought that and issued
achieve 100% accuracy are arbitrary long
test beta
I should also be generic so we hope that
our models our our approach can be
handled different styles of languages
without any specific tuning right not
with specific tuning so without any
additional design to to tailor for these
for the different languages and then we
we will demonstrate in our example that
our approach can handle also imperative
language and under functional lambda
language and right so this is the
high-level idea of our approach so we
want to learn a neuro program operating
are non differentiable machine so then
here is the idea so given our input so
the neural program will constantly meet
the next instruction to be executed by
the underlining parsing machine
and then the parsing machine will return
like the environment observation our
argument to the neural processing
program so that they can predict the
next instruction and there are several
iterations then the the neural program
will meet the final final instruction
that means the program has been executed
and the execution can be terminated and
then in the end the are the predictions
are also should be emitted by the
parsing machine directly so so while we
are using this because we found several
other architectures as our other
problems share the same saying can be
modeled in the same module for
you know theorems theorem proving with
her so we have a premises and we have a
conclusion we want to construct the
intermediate lemmas one after another
and then for the program synthesis the
general program synthesis we have the
precondition and the post condition and
then we can generate every line of the
code to meet this requirement a more
increasingly architecture searches also
belongs to this category so we have the
input data we have the output prediction
we want to generate the intermediate
representation of of different archive
of the internal structure of the neural
networks so that they can so that's what
the office can be very close to the
ground truth
okay so and then by employing this idea
we need to we need to do two levels of
innovation wise we need to define a new
non-differentiable machine first and
also we need to the design your neuro
program so that they can be learned from
input output pair only ok so this is so
to achieve this code we designed this
cook on our machine so the name is cut
out but actually it's a hybrid between
the parsing algorithm and the LR parsing
algorithm ok so I won't talk detail
about this parsing algorithm but
basically it employs a stack structure
so that it will parse up it will pass
every sub expression in in the new stack
frame and once the new subjects pressure
is reduced into into a single into a
non-terminal node it will be returned to
the previous stack frame so that it can
be further actually executed recursively
to construct the entire logic tree
ok so this is a basic idea of the ir
machine and then for the partner of
parsing program oh one property of the
strength machine is that on every frame
of the stack there so it not only
contains one element but contains this
was on fib and the leaves of different
non terminals that will be constructed
as the children of the root
okay and then so for each so our machine
will contain five different types of
instructions and then twelve them why
it's code reviews that the other is
called call and then twelve them will
have arguments so our our neural parsing
program will based only on the spec top
this is why this algorithm can be
generalized to arbitrary input because
it's not depending on the whole input
but only on the inner stack top and then
based on the top it will predicted in
the instruct where s PM is used to
predict the instruction time on twatter
allottee and are used to predict the
arguments so right so you see our
interest i can talk more about the
architecture after the after this one so
so by employing this kind of structure
we can't guarantee that they can fully
generalized to arbitrary input places
once we design the feeling hoppers okay
so the main challenge is still here we
have only input-output pairs so we don't
have dialing feature increases then to
recover these acts experiences is a very
challenging problem because even for
very simple input X plus y it has nice
types to convert an input token sequence
into the final output right so then our
idea is to use up with as a user
reinforcement learning based algorithm
but if we does employ the for example
the policy greedy algorithm naively then
we have a lot of trouble right so so
here I will briefly mention the
challenges that we will get during
during this process and briefly explain
our solution so the first one is that
the policy greeting will be simple and
will very easily get tracked into in at
some local optimum so what I what I mean
is that so for every input because it is
if you only look at one input then there
are various kind of a set of production
rules that kind converting input into
the parsing tree and then in this case
so the policy if we just look at one
example then the pol
network anchor stuck into an L any of
these grammar or production rules and
then also if we will only look at one of
them it is unclear which one is the
correct one right so this is the first
problem and also also if we combine
several examples together it is very
hard for in one policy network to to
feed them all so for example two and to
achieve 100% reading accuracy so during
our finding if we just run simple policy
reading we never observed that we can
achieve 100% reading accuracy under
finding on Infineon data right so the
whole is of these so the approach that
we take is that the high level idea is
that okay so I really input all freedom
who we have a set of we have a set of
feasible faces then then we just want to
get a combination of these trees so know
for every input output pair we want to
get one trees and then and then for
example a collection of six different
input-output pairs we get a fixed races
and then we just want to find the
correct one so that one policy can
achieve 100% training accuracy on all
these changes data then the basic idea
is very simple so for area in falafel
pairs we sample we first collect all
these visible traces and then we sample
one for each pair then we can enhance
the data set so learners the visitor has
only info prepares by Ray now we have
input alpha trip trees triple okay and
then we can freedom policy networks to
see whether they can achieve 100 percent
really random so if this is the case
then we find a good policy or otherwise
then we repeat to step two and we
resample these trees and also we have
some algorithm to adjust the sample
distribution about how we sample them
but those details you can take a look at
the paper I will not talk about them so
using this approach we have we can solve
the
so using this approach we can we can't
it's not easy but it is feasible that we
can find the good policy but there is
one subtle problem in here it's because
there are too many feasible faces so if
we just look at the sequence of a
sequence of nine instructions each
instruction each instruction may have
five types and for each type so for two
of these types they may have tens of
possible arguments for example the
reduce and the call instruction may have
many different possible arguments so
that's a huge amount of fossil fuel
amount of possible choices now how do we
solve this problem right so usually just
clean them then the total total total
number of feasible pieces will be
exponentially many so that better too
many so to mitigate this problem we
treat the with lead the search of the
instruction type and argument separately
so then we then we invent this idea
called prophase learning where one
problem is that for each improper pair
we only son for the trees with our
argument so with only instruction type
and then so this is this dentists that
becomes manageable and then then by
removing the trees there is not for
supervised learning problem so so then
we invent a new weekly supervised
learning problem algorithm to solve the
- to solve how do we find the correct
argument so then then we decouple the
two problems every day so it right
because I don't have a lot of time so I
can cannot see stream too many details
but I'd like to demonstrate our
experimental results so basically we
will consider two languages they are not
full-fledged language but there are very
simple languages and why is the
imperative online is functional and then
we compared to two based language that
sequence of seasons model the other is
sequence two three model and then we
build two
is that why is the curriculum learning
because reinforcement learning requires
current training curriculum and then
this crazy land it has had contain only
100 to 150 you samples off lands less
than 10 but however for these two
sequences in this model they cannot be
trained on too small such smarted at
that so we we enhance the curriculum
learning with into the so-called
standard trees that we buy randomly
generate 110 thousand different kind of
inputs of last ten ten for the test that
we randomly generate three different
types of lines to be turned 100 1000 so
we have observed that for the type set
of which containing examples last would
1,000 the the lands is 100 times longer
than the input input training examples
and here are the youth varmint results
we have observed that for our approach
no matter we finish the curriculum are
always the largest as it offers we are
the same they can achieve 100 percent
testing accuracy are all these different
data set but very instantly for the
difference for the difference for the
sequence of synchronous model and the
signal to free model even on these are
on the standard training set they cannot
achieve 100 percent accuracy one when
they are evaluated on the longer so if
we evaluate them on the longer that I
said diversity all top below there are
all top to zero but even on the test
that which have the same line such as
the fina data the accuracy is less than
20 around 20 percent so that is pretty
low
see oh no no it doesn't have Yeah right
so right that is on the well language
and for the lambda and for the function
language it is a little simpler because
we have the the test accuracy right now
it's more than 86% right but for the
season so Susan's model the accuracy is
still very low right so the
demonstrate that our approach is much
more effective in terms of the generator
and generalization and handling
different kind of languages okay so the
main takeaway here is that I want to
promote these kind of building Nura
program the model to do the neural
problems on top of non-differentiable
bond machines and then using this kind
of architecture we can achieve much
better generalization properties and
then fully differentiable Europe our
neural networks right so and then we
found that during our study even though
I don't talk a lot about that but the
desire of the non-differentiable machine
for example to our machine is very
critical to make this problem to be
learn about right so yes
motivation of this parsha learning
problem so the intention is going to get
lots of input into strong yes right so
this is a cool question
so for example when you design a new DSL
a new to mr. Pacific language maybe in
some small applications so in this case
you may you may you may not need to
write a formal formal putter using
lights or lights are young or NPR art is
kind of cool you may only want to
provide okay this is the important and
it's part raised like this and I will
hope you can provide the part was in the
challenges we do right exactly really
that's a so photo for the use Apple for
the new sample here right that's a very
good question for this for the example
in our experiment or we take around 10
to our no 100 - 100 to 150 different
examples in the phenotype and the
production rule is around 100 different
kind of rules right I don't I don't
recall the exact number but uh right
around the winery
different kind of production rules but
the point is that it is very tricky to
get those production rule wrong right so
but you can demos it by showing okay so
for this input this parse tree should
look like this and not look like that
then then this is a much more intuitive
way for human being for human being to
generate than writing the rigorous
production rule right so rapid that can
be a cool question but and also for this
problem is it's not really even though
we think this problem itself is
important but also diseases first up
offer another progress that we are
really not right yet so so basically
that here is our conclusion so we have
talked a lot about how the building
secure applications is very challenging
and demanding and then we we have
demonstrate that this entire network are
vulnerable to adverse are examples also
without with mostly some preliminary
result how we can use deep learning
technologies for how program analysis
and problem synthesis ok yeah so right
so that's all here are our collaborators
and thank you very much for the part I'm
not sure if I still have time to take
some questions maybe
for Christmas how long missing so I I
join you might have ago so so for the
newer parts or hopefully using your
networks okay oh it's very actually it's
very small so we only use one of our
young women
let me I don't want the number of family
I need maybe thousands the Helen Keaney
unit is right there are five is a
different the hidden spaces of alcohol
per page so and then the transition
table I think so there there is I miss
are fitted by 13 matrix in there so
pharmacy a few thousand parameters speak
fashionable this I can see for your
particular the status of the
non-differentiable protecting the
sponsor is not differentiable so this is
a ho Ponte yet the house we found out
you to use the differentiable circuit is
very hard to get 100% accuracy
right
also this is also demonstrate so so this
idea to to to you to combine the to
combine the neuro program is a stack is
not new so it was it was invented into a
1990s and the DA was called push start
to push down automata and then even even
in 2004 15 there is a paper on this
topic but they demonstrate that even for
seem very simple context-free language
the accuracy is not 100% so so that so
so this is why this kind of
differentiable machine is not within our
consideration at the first place because
we hope our first goal is to achieve 100
function in general pass accuracy right
I hear I'm at fault here